hi i'm max kaiser this is the kaiser
report you know we've been talking a lot
about inflation deflation stagflation
disinflation and hyperinflation a lot of
uh inflation's out there
stacy
right hyperinflation is in the news but
in my own day-to-day experience
i've witnessed
hyper shrink flesh
yes you know last sunday we were out
having brunch and i ordered some avocado
this is what came to me
that is not an avocado i could believe
in that is a hyper shrink flation i
would call that that's a minuscule order
of avocado and it was a direct slap in
the face it was a direct indication of
what's happening out there in the
economy prices are just going up and
people are hiding it by serving smaller
portions at the same prices we've seen
this at the grocery store with packaged
goods packaged cookies packaged
toiletries like
toothpaste and mouthwash coming in
smaller packages but the same price and
people haven't noticed it but things are
getting out of control
this is a hyper shrink inflation
hopefully we'll see a hyper inflation
and some of the population we have quite
a large size but nevertheless i was
pretty shocked by this but of course you
know hyperinflation was in the news
because a ceo actually said this you and
i have covered it on kaiser report this
hyperinflation michael bury brought this
up he's a hedge fund guy who made a big
amount of money on a big short on the
u.s housing market back in 2008 2009 but
um he recently had said that warned of
hyperinflation and looked at uh weimar
germany as an example well now jack
dorsey
you know last weekend as well while we
were suffering from hyperschrenflation
he was he must have seen my tweet
because that's what he
inspired him to tweet hyperinflation is
going to change
everything
it's happening
that triggered many people
yeah it did uh because these words
inflation deflation disinflation shrink
flation
are all kind of misunderstood and
misused now to be clear
hyperinflation is a political act it's
and whereas inflation is a more of a
monetary act so
hyperinflation is when loss
in the currency evaporates so in
venezuela or in weimar germany
or in iran
confidence in that fiat money disappears
and it literally plunges we're seeing it
in turkey as well the u.s of course
having the world reserve currency you
would think is immune to hyperinflation
but
they have done such a poor job over at
the central bank of the treasury
department and in the white house itself
over the past 20 years that it looks
highly probable that confidence in the
u.s dollar is about to completely
evaporate so purchasing power for that
currency is about to crash down towards
zero and there will be a blame game
going on that it wasn't their own
actions of excessive money printing it
wasn't their own actions of
turning your money the u.s dollar was a
world's reserve currency it was the
settlement layer it was the world's
money based on u.s treasury's
base
layer money
they turned it from money which is
always fungible money is fungible
they made it a non-fungible token by
pulling iran off the swift system
therefore it was no longer fungible that
meant it was um it was inevitably over
this moment was coming from that
that day that you decided to win the
battle by losing the war
that happened yellen
says i don't think we're about to lose
control of inflation this came just like
36 hours after jack dorsey had triggered
a huge conversation about hyperinflation
so janet yellen the treasury secretary
of the united states in charge of
maintaining the value of the currency
she comes out and says uh you know
officially denied
that
right the uh verbiage and rhetoric that
came out of the treasury and central
bank during the 1973 period in america
right before a massive inflation hit is
almost verbatim what we're hearing today
the big difference being that the
inflation of the 70s was transitory
genuinely transitory because america was
being held hostage by the oil producing
countries but this is actually
structural inflation and in fact
hyperinflation this is when confidence
in the currency
evaporates and there's no way to put the
humpty dumpty back together again once
it falls off the wall it's cracked and
you cannot reassemble it once you lose
confidence you know it took 240 years
for the world to obtain confidence in
the u.s currency and it only took really
18 months for it to be lost well you
definitely know that we're hitting
hyperinflation when we replace our
flowers with you know origami of us
dollars hundred dollar bills right we're
going to start uh having to replace
these yeah first we'll have a cactus you
know that's the way that you can
mitigate your floral costs
and then you go into origami
paper
concoctions of made of paper money for
flowers not only did the treasury
secretary yell in last weekend she said
okay
we are not about to lose control of
inflation
and at the other side of her mouth she
said oh we're going to start taxing
unrealized gains for the 700
billionaires in america
so recognizing that inflation is
happening inflation is driving up stock
prices inflation is driving up asset
values but there's no way to get it
because
by the way the velocity of money
what we've identified long ago is you
know do you think elon musk is going to
spend any more in his day-to-day life
today when he's worth almost 300 billion
versus when he was only worth 3 billion
there's not going to be that much more
so how do you get that cash just sitting
there and doing nothing right well
they're going to start taxing all those
gains the stock prices soaring
and i want to point to something that
adam back who is um quoted in the white
paper the bitcoin white paper so he's a
uh cipher punk and a coder and what he
said about
this
plan to tax unrealized gains the
insanity of this is not fully
appreciated
they create the inflation debasing your
savings and then if you somehow manage
to cling on to some of the value by
taking on investment risk they then
propose taxing you on the so-called gain
they directly caused by devaluing the
dollar
and it's he goes on in a second tweet
it's actually worse than a wealth tax
think about it
as the dollar hyperinflates
they can take more money even if the
investment is standing still in real
terms or even if your investment is
actually losing money but losing less
than m2 monetary expansion inflation
rates so i guess this is what they're
learning from weimar germany looking
back at what happened during weimar
germany is those who bought assets
and those who borrowed to buy assets the
industrialists saw this hyperinflation
coming they
the the industrials who ran the economy
started to lose faith in the value of
the vikes mark and then they um started
to borrow against it and buy assets and
they won right so the treasury is
looking at this and saying we're not
going to let you escape
our doomed plan
right right it's a speculative attack
that they're worried about and this is
exactly what michael saylor
microstrategy figured out he can borrow
at these incredibly low rates and buy
bitcoin and he's already made billions
of dollars in less than a year doing
exactly that now he's bringing in other
ceos other countries
like el salvador figured this out other
countries will figure this out i think
that's the bigger story here is that
janet yellen and
jay powell over the fed don't control
the global
economy so america may opt out of having
a viable currency by imposing this
absurd
tax but it just means that the dollar is
going to crash it doesn't mean that
bitcoin's going to crash or that gold is
going to crash
it's going to help bitcoin because
confidence in the dollar when you have
policies like this that could have been
arranged by bernie madoff this is like
having bernie madoff run your treasury
it's a ponzi scheme and what the
reaction is going to be
is a flight to bitcoin uh so you know
bring it on i'm happy however likely
what they would do
they would
determine your gains for the year on
december 31st
those same 700 people own the vast
majority of the stock market do you
think the stock market is ever going to
end on december 31st in gain no it's
gonna go down they're going to make
money off it by writing those unrealized
losses off of their taxes and then
things will resume back to normal
january 1st so that's that's all that's
going to happen and then they'll have to
go after
the joe bagadonis the next 700 000
people right they print money it ends up
in these assets and they say the way
we're going to claw back that money that
we printed is to tax unrealized gains
but of course if they're truly
interested in stopping the madness they
would stop printing so much money
that's the root of the problem
obviously i think anyone with a third
grade education would see that
that's the root of the problem but since
it's a ponzi scheme you can never
stop the flow of the base layer that
feeds the ponzi pyramid
so this is an admission in fact that
this is nothing more than a ponzi scheme
and it just adds
to the flight out of the dollar there
it's literally like watching a country
commit currency aside um which is
remarkable there but i guess weimar
germany did the same thing they actually
just committed financial suicide and of
course great britain did that with
brexit they committed financial suicide
so there you have it but let's turn to
the story of the hyperinflation on the
and what you're seeing and actual
signals being sent by the people
obviously signals price signals are
being destroyed at the federal reserve
level but what the individuals are doing
with all this free money being sent to
them is mass consumption they're buying
anything they can get even used cars are
going up in price they're worth more
sometimes than the new cars because you
could at least sell them there's a price
being determined they're sending all
those that free money over to china
china's buying productive assets here
owning more and more of the world by the
way now china wants to get back into
bitcoin mining now that they see that
all their depreciating value of that but
it's causing a supply crunch and the
entropy of the end of empire days you
see
as a result in this headline here
charlotte county utilities department
calling for voluntary water conservation
so this is a county of 188 000 people in
florida over near sarasota gulf coast
and it gets the vast majority of his
water from the peace river minnesota
regional supply authority they've got
two treatment plants down and they can't
get the parts they need in order to pump
the water south michael coats manages
the district water supply and said
capacity is down and demand is rising
demand is rising everybody's got free
money they're all working from home they
want to drink more they want to shower
more they've got pools well apparently
the parts are on ships hanging off the
long beach ports and they can't get the
water to be cleared for uh distribution
to homes right great great point because
okay they want to collect more money the
government does and so what are they
going to do with the money a they're
going to put into infrastructure like
cleaning water filters in charlotte so
people don't die from drinking arsenic
the you know labels polluted water or b
they give it to speculators who are
speculating on assets who have margin
calls because they're over indebted what
do they do with the money they're going
to collect they're going to give it to
the speculators none of the money ever
goes into infrastructure
none of the money collected by us
government ever goes into infrastructure
okay that's not what american government
does
like nancy pelosi and senate and
congress and jay pal the fed and central
bankers they traded inside information
provable now documented and they make
lots of money and they're contempt of
the american people makes marie
antoinette look like mother teresa all
right we're going to take a break and
when we come back much more coming your
way
[Music]
welcome back to the kaiser report i'm
max kaiser time now to go to tyson
slocum of public citizens energy program
tyson also serves on the cftc's energy
committee energy is bigger than news as
the u.n climate change summit opens
tomorrow in an energy crisis in the form
of soaring oil and natural gas prices
hits
economies globally tyson's welcome let's
start with the u.n climate change summit
cop 26 as this summit kicks off tomorrow
in glasgow should we expect anything
more other than the same well i mean i
think it's great that the united states
is back engaged with the rest of the
world as you know the biden
administration reversed course from
trump and re-entered the paris climate
accord and so the biden administration
uh with john kerry and others are going
to be at the table
pushing the world to try and move these
negotiations along i don't think that
uh
that these meetings are going to result
in anything earth-shattering
but just the fact that the united states
is re-engaging and continues to
prioritize action on climate
uh at the regulatory and legislative
level means that i think that there's
hope for the planet that we don't
destroy it yet that the world is at
least engaged in trying to figure out a
global solution to uh to climate change
let me ask you this which came first uh
money printing out of control or the
global climate change crisis i think
about the same time i think uh they both
were sort of there with the industrial
revolution and the burning of fossil
fuels to meet all of our energy needs so
i think uh it's an opportunity to maybe
address both problems at once what do
you think you know the the idea of this
esg which is uh rebranding of corporate
social responsibility in climate space
seems to be justification to print a few
more trillion dollars
um and um
the
excessive money printing
uh results in mal investment including
30 of all the energy produced is wasted
because the companies who use energy are
not incentivized to use it
efficiently so we're rewarding the worst
amongst us it seems like cop 26 is a
festival of malinvestment
i i don't know if i would characterize
it that way i think that
that global climate change requires a
global solution and so i think it
actually is productive and important for
world leaders to get together on a
regular basis and figure out a way
to comprehensively address the climate
crisis uh but yeah i think individual
nations commitments i think are going to
be a little underwhelming i think this
is just sort of the first step of many
needed steps to get to where we we need
to go two months ago us president joe
biden called on saudi arabia to pump
more oil in order to lower prices for us
consumers and yet this weekend
uh we're supposed to believe that biden
actually wants less oil pumped you see
what i'm saying here there seems to be a
bit of uh hypocrisy yes i agree that
there's there's some hypocrisy here
especially when he didn't
address the domestic situation the
united states oil and gas industry over
the last several years has completely
reoriented itself away from prioritizing
investment for domestic consumption of
fossil fuels and towards the
international export of u.s produced gas
and oil and so if you look at almost all
major
uh u.s oil and natural gas
infrastructure investments they're
designed to prioritize exporting those
fossil fuels out of the united states
and so those rising levels of x4 right
we're now exporting about 10 billion
cubic feet per day of natural gas we're
exporting several million barrels of
crude oil every day and plus millions
more of refined products like gasoline
this is all having an upward pressure on
domestic
uh gas and oil prices which is hurting
consumers so if if biden was going to be
serious
about addressing the price crisis and
the the climate crisis he would be
taking steps to limit or ban u.s fossil
fuel exports right well you know the
price of oil is going up just like all
commodities
because there's too much money printing
they're floating the system with too
many dollars
so you know why don't they address the
problem i i don't understand why
i don't get it man you know these people
are obviously frauds they are just
printing to line their own pockets and
they claim to be concerned about the
climate but they're not they're clearly
not they're not how can anyone believe
them tyson well there is a credibility
problem with with the federal reserve as
i'm sure you know there's there's a lot
of scandals and there's a serious push
to uh
not extend the chairmanship for powell
and so there's a lot of heat right now
on the fed but i think that we've got to
put some heat on
uh limiting us fossil fuel exports and
biden has that clear authority i i
helped work on the 2015 law
and there's provisions in there all
biden has to do is say that there's a
problem with u.s oil exports and put a
notice in the federal register
and we can take steps to start to limit
or stop uh crude oil exports and the
same goes on on natural gas all of the
uh natural gas export authorizations
include what's known as clawback uh
clauses that allow the department of
energy which authorizes lng exports
to claw back authorizations of those
exports if
uh
uh unexpected or severe changes occur
like climate change or rising prices or
physical shortages like we saw in uh
during the february winter storm so all
of these things are a clear indication
that we've got to
limit or stop our fossil uh
fuel export booth you know i know you do
a lot of research and you're crunching
the numbers there all day long let me
ask you a question here because i have
no idea what the answer is i'm if you've
done any work on this but when a rental
car company i believe it's hertz orders
a hundred thousand cars from tesla
electric vehicles is that a net positive
i don't know i i haven't looked at the
details of this announcement but uh
the the climate crisis is not going to
be solved by swapping internal
combustion engine ceiling powered
vehicles
with
the same number or more uh fully
electric cars it's not until we change
modes of trend of transit to get more
mass transit investments
uh are we going to see meaningful change
on addressing climate from the
transportation uh sector so uh i'm not
as i mean you know electrification of
individual automobiles and trucks
plays an important role in
decarbonization
but it alone is not going to be the
savior or the solution
we've got to
re-envision transportation to have a lot
more uh efficient uh mass transit okay
so leaked documents before this cop
event showed uh saudi arabia australia
japan have been lobbying the u.n to
play down the need to move rapidly away
from fossil fuels
so uh what's that all about
well it's nice to know that the us isn't
villain number one in global climate
talks but what's going on here is that
you know vested interests whether it be
the saudi national oil company or the
significant uh coal and natural gas
interests in australia
are continuing to be relevant in the
face of this uh change to a decarbonized
future and
and playing a very influential role in a
number of key countries to try and slow
down uh the commitments but we have to
remember at this point the paris climate
accord was an all-voluntary set of
commitments that's why president obama
who negotiated it never had to bring it
up to the u.s senate for ratification
the constitution requires all uh foreign
treaties to be ratified by the united
states senate
and paris
the paris climate accord wasn't a treaty
because there was
zero binding commitments all you have to
do is voluntarily and publicly commit to
a uh an emission reduction scheme
and then if you fail to do it you're
just publicly shamed by having other
leaders wag their fingers at you but
there's no uh uh sanctions or other
financial or regulatory penalties for
non-compliance and so so we do have to
understand that right now these
international commitments
are really just sort of
you know
uh they're they're not binding and so in
order for us to have really effective
international means to address the
climate crisis i think we've got to put
a lot more meat on these uh
international agreements right well in
the meantime however bitcoin
is incentivizing stranded clean
geothermal energy to be captured in one
of the poorest countries in the world el
salvador and they're converting it into
hard money
what lessons can we draw from this
well i think that the the bitcoin and
crypto mining industry is sort of
learning a lot from big tech
companies like google and microsoft that
were building energy intensive servers
to power the internet and they
recognized that those servers were
contributing to climate problems and
committed to renewable energy and other
sustainable energy uh resources to power
those data centers and i think
uh the the crypto mining industry is
doing very similar things here where
they're recognizing that uh using all
these servers uh uh does use uh some
energy and making commitments to uh uh
power them in more sustainable ways
we're seeing it with talon energy which
owns a nuclear power plant in
pennsylvania
uh latching that nuclear power plant to
uh crypto mining uh like you said uh
utilizing all sorts of uh industrial
processes that are capturing wasted uh
uh heat to to power these facilities
there's a whole host of things that
crypto mining can easily do to uh um
uh you know reduce the the climate
impacts of its operations right but
there's another part of this uh they the
president of the company buchelli is
openly mocking
the imf on twitter and about the loans
and the
colonialization that's been going on
from people like the un and the imf and
the world bank and all these uh huge
groups that seem obsessed with climate
change and they're replacing it with
real money hard money so until the us
gets off fiat money the chances of
solving the the climate crisis is zero i
would give it a big fat zero because you
can't solve the crisis with fake play
money tyson
well i i don't know if i'd go that far
but there's no question that i think
crypto can play a productive uh an
important role in the financial system
and that i i don't necessarily view uh
uh crypto mining as a problem for the
climate like others do right well it's
not a problem for the climate it's it's
it requires uh one tenth of one percent
of the global energy output to secure
hard money for eight billion people
potentially so it your overall global
energy usage would be cut at least in
half
if folk i'm just saying if they were
serious
they would adopt bitcoin mining
as the go-to model to cut global
emissions right uh that would be the
serious thing to do at this point
because the data is in
but they're not anyway we're gonna take
a we're going to carry this over to part
two thank you for being on kaiser report
oh always great to be here max thank you
all right that's going to do it for this
edition of the kaiser report with me max
keiser and stacey herbert want to thank
our guest tyson slocum until next time
bye y'all
[Music]